Friday night just after 11 p.m.  3 minutes earlier Boris Nemtsov was shot  dead on a bridge near the Kremlin a  journalist with the radio station Ekho  Moskvy was driving toward the famed st.  Basil's Cathedral to the left the  kremlin wall then this white car  appeared Russian media are showing the  scene filmed by a dashboard camera it's  rumored that this is the escape vehicle  and that it's a government car Russian  officials have confirmed neither claim  but investigators do say they've  identified preliminary suspects speaking  to the interior ministry President  Vladimir Putin condemned the crime  publicly for the first time we must read  Russia of disgraces and tragedies like  the one we just saw the brazen murder of  Boris Nemtsov right in the centre of the  capital around the world many remain  outraged about the murder they want to  see the crime solved this video may  provide a clue that's sure to be closely  scrutinized